es una escena caótica los manifestantes
iraquíes crean insultos contra irán
mientras irrumpen en el parlamento
principalmente seguidores del influyente
clérigo múqtada sádr
muchos agitan su foto en alto
hoy estamos en su lugar de trabajo y
mañana iremos a sus casas
[Aplausos]
estamos en el parlamento por orden de
nuestro querido líder múqtada al sádr
tenemos un mensaje especial para los
corruptos los injustos y para el
ciudadano los manifestantes pro múqtada
al sádr están enfadados por la elección
de la candidatura de un bloque rival
para primer ministro mohamed al daini ex
ministro que es la elección pro iraní
del marco de coordinación para la
jefatura de gobierno
hemos votado nos hemos sacrificado
durante muchos años y exigimos reformas
y un cambio de régimen
múqtada al sádr parecía estar a punto de
tomar el poder después de que su bloque
obtuviera 73 escaños en las elecciones
parlamentarias del pasado octubre pero
las conversaciones para formar un
gobierno se estancaron y sus
legisladores abandonaron en masa al
recinto por orden del clérigo a raíz de
estas últimas protestas el primer
ministro interino mustafa al qadi me ha
hecho un llamado a la calma
irak se vio sacudido por manifestaciones
masivas en 2019 ya que la mayoría de los
jóvenes expresaron su rabia por la
corrupción y el desempleo en el país
rico en petróleo a raíz de los
disturbios se reformó el sistema
electoral pero más de nueve meses
después de la última elección el bloqueo
político se mantiene y el país sigue sin
gobierno la crisis tiene a irak sin
presupuesto para este año retrasando
proyectos clave para el desarrollo de la
nación